all right so uh The Last of Us series
must have infected the minds of everyone
because it is the biggest show ever
right now and since we covered the
history of Joel Miller last week it's
time we move on to his counterpart for a
majority of this post-apocalyptic story
Ellie Williams yeah I had no clue that
was her last name either but we're going
to be explaining Ellie's Journey fill in
the backstory from the comics and The
Last of Us DLC her story in The Last of
Us Part Two and whether or not she's
actually the real deal here at the
center of all of this obviously spoilers
for the game and potential ones for the
series so quietly sneak out of here if
you don't want those but please clicker
that like And subscribe Button as it
keeps you updated on all of our last of
us coverage with that out of the way
though a huge thank you for clicking
this I'm your host Jared now let's get
into the last of us so the first two
episodes of the series slowly entered
produce us to Ellie and honestly has
been really faithful to the game's
Source material Ellie was born after the
cordyceps infection outbreak roughly in
the spring of 2019 so with the 10-year
difference between the game and the
series it would be 2009 in the series
anyway her mother was a nurse named Anna
while her father was unknown he was
never actually identified in the source
material so I don't know he probably
went out and got some milk and just got
bit but unfortunately Anna passed away
giving birth to Ellie granting
guardianship to Marlene the member of
the fireflies as she had promised to
take care of Ellie in this moment
however her idea of taking care of Ellie
basically meant placing her in an
orphanage in the Boston qz and later a
military boarding school so for all of
those years Ellie learned the nonsense
that Federer was trying to teach them
about the new world with little
knowledge of the old world before the
infection Ellie finally met Marlene when
she was 13 years old learning about her
mother and so forth now roughly a year
later when Elias 14 is when the game and
series introduce her under Marlene's
care needing to be transported to the
other group of the fireflies this is
also of course where Joel and Ellie
begin their father-daughter relationship
with neither of them really trusting one
another Joel and Tess take on the job of
transporting La however are caught by
some QC security as the three are being
scanned for the infection Ellie is in a
frantic matter and stabs one of the
guards with some slight differences
between the game and the series here but
it's revealed that Ellie has been bitten
and is infected however it soon
discovered that this bite is weeks old
and she has yet to turn this is why
Marlene needed the pair to transport her
to the other fireflies as she's
essentially looked at as the closest
thing to a cure in a roundabout way she
is a chosen one in this dark dystopian
future the trio Trek out on the journey
delivering this teenage degenerate to
the fireflies so then they can and
conduct all of this research on her
therefore developing a cure now there
are some moments here or there where
Ellie mentions how she got infected
how did you get bit
you know the old Mall in the QC I snuck
in
wanted to see what it was like so it was
just you in there alone
yeah
there's also the mention of a character
Riley a time or two all of this
backstory and relationship building to
this was told in a four issue comic The
Last of Us American Dreams along with
the Left Behind DLC now let's go back a
bit as the American Dreams comic is set
roughly a year before Joel and Tess are
tasked with transporting Ellie shortly
after Ellie's 13th birthday she is
attending a federa military boarding
school in the Boston qz here it's kind
of hinted that tensions are running a
little hotter as a military guard that
knows Ellie tells her that he can't look
after her anymore and she better not try
to pull any of her old stunts Ellie with
the sassy attitude that she has
obviously doesn't listen to this advice
quickly getting into an altercation with
a group of boys trying to steal her
belongings luckily Ellie is saved by
another teenage girl provoking the boys
she gives Ellie advice about the Boston
qz and remarks on Ellie's trust issues
before running for from other authority
figures at this time Ellie is tasked
with cleaning duties at the school
because of her poor rap sheet at
previous homes during the day of
cleaning a bloodied Jeep she realizes
her Walkman is missing and that the
mysterious teenage girl that she had
talked to a couple days ago was the one
that snatched it Ellie confronts her in
the lunchroom getting the Walkman back
but is made fun of for her poor music
taste later that night Ellie notices
this other girl sneaking out Ellie
follows her and eventually finds out her
name is Riley which if you've played the
Left Behind DLC you you of course know
this sorry I'm getting ahead of myself
here but this Knight is full of Firsts
for Ellie as they explore the abandoned
Mall Ellie learns to ride a horse from
Riley's friend Winston they help the
fireflies Escape fedra gunfire and later
have altercations with both infected and
the same fireflies that they helped at
this point Ellie discovers Marlene had
people watching over her her entire life
because of the promise that she made to
her mother Anna Marlene hands Ellie an
envelope with a letter from her mother
along with the iconic switchblade that
we see Ellie pull out in episode 2 along
with her using in the game this was a
gift from her mother and that's why it's
such a treasured Memento to Ellie and
why she's never without it this evening
of shenanigans though was the spark of
friendship we later see ignite between
Ellie and Riley in the Left Behind DLC
Story the two later had a falling out
after an argument with Riley
disappearing Ellie was then drafted into
the military unsure whether or not Riley
died or was even ever coming back to the
Boston qz but in the summer of 2033
Riley sneaks back into the school to see
Ellie after being gone for roughly six
weeks Riley urges Ellie to sneak out
telling her she's become a firefly now
and that the fireflies are far different
from the line fedra military soldiers of
which El is now becoming evading patrols
the pair head out to the Liberty Gardens
Mall the same Mall Ellie earlier learned
to ride Winston's horse hear
conversations about their previous fight
their future their friendships are
interwoven with the pair exploring
different stores and shenanigans like
trying on Halloween masks and taking
snapshots in a photo booth against
fedra's claims they returned power to
the mall and ride in illuminated
Carousel in the courtyard Ellie
continues to press Riley about her
return with her saying that the
fireflies are actually relocating her to
a different Hideout and she wanted to
see Ellie before this Ellie buries her
true feelings about this Revelation and
eventually leads to them playing Ellie's
Walkman over a speaker system in an
electronic store the two danced on the
counters until Ellie suddenly stops
saddened that her friend is leaving
Ellie asks Riley not to leave with the
fireflies and Riley responds by taking
off her Firefly pen and dropping it on
the ground Ellie leans in and kisses
Riley but it's a bit embarrassing for
her so she instantly apologizes but
Riley tells her that there's no need to
be sorry the two would begin to discuss
what to do next however the loud music
of course attracts a group of infected
Runners to them all the two escape a
majority of them taking out one of the
last ones but it soon realized that both
Ellie and Riley were bitten in the
run-in and now are infected of course
this means certain death as they discuss
ending it right then and there or
waiting it out enjoying the last few
moments that they have together the two
decide on the latter option but after
some time Riley is the only one to fall
to the cordyceps infection Ellie
survives therefore assuming she's immune
back in Marlene's care the two realize
this is a miracle case and Marlene plans
to take Ellie to the Firefly lab in Salt
Lake City now this is where we were
before jumping back to the comic and DLC
stories Ellie is paired up with Joel and
Tess to be transported to the other
fireflies but now knowing a bit more of
her backstory you can see how she
suffered from not only that PTSD at the
moment but also survivor's guilt her
best friend Riley fell to the infection
while she didn't so um yeah that's some
heavy for a 14 year old to deal with
during the start of this journey Ellie's
trust issues are in high gear because
Joel and Tess are strangers But as time
passes the travesties that they
witnessed together is what brings them
closer Ellie in a way can relate to Joel
losing Tess after being bitten and
infected and she has a bit of sympathy
for Joel's clouded past especially
losing his daughter Sarah on outbreak
day Ellie having never left the qz
experiences nothing but new first
similar to that first night that she
snuck out with Riley on the way to
Bill's town in search of a car battery
Ellie has never been in the woods in
Bill's Town she's never seen a comic
book also a nudie magazine but a moving
on as Ellie and Joel Venture from Boston
to Salt Lake City the two each have
their bonding and breaking moments
essentially Ellie just wants to help win
and where she can while Joel very much
pictures her as a helpless child due to
his last moments with Sarah but Ellie is
able to have Joel warm up to her
teaching her how to shoot a rifle open
up about Sarah and also his not so moral
life in that 20-some years between the
initial outbreak and now another
defining moment for Ellie is when they
meet Henry and Sam when trying to avoid
the hunters in the Pittsburgh area the
brotherly Duo helped the pair out while
also giving Ellie someone her own age to
actually relate to a friend if you will
up until this moment a lot of the
strangers that they ran into turned out
to be vile and have ulterior motives but
the brothers are genuinely nice guys
Ellie even grabs a toy from one of the
abandoned shops to give to Sam later but
like most of the other things in Ellie's
life this relationship sours when Sam is
infected and Henry ends up taking his
own life after losing his brother this
very much reminds Ellie of her
survivor's guilt and almost moves the
needle more towards Joel's feelings of
hopelessness and nothing lasts forever
in a matter of a couple months this has
happened to Ellie twice now by the end
of 2023 the pair finally make it to
Jackson County Wyoming and find Joel's
brother Tommy he was supposed to know
about where the fireflies were at with
Joel attempting to actually Pawn off
Ellie towards him and then he can just
return back to Boston though Ellie
caught wind of this frustrated she ran
off Joel and Tommy found her but then
had to fight off some Bandits which
actually caused Joel to kind of have a
change of heart as the two's
relationship essentially turned into
that father-daughter relationship that
we see at the end of The Last of Us Part
One however Ellie has to take the lead
role of the pair after they arrive at
the Colorado University campus
discovering the fireflies have fled to
Salt Lake City and Joel is brutally
injured after falling on some Rogue
rebar during the fight with some Bandits
Ellie barely gets him up and out of
there but then slowly nurses him back to
health with scram Lounge together
supplies from an abandoned Mall Ellie
later hides Joel in a house near the
Lakeside Resort during the winter months
only leaving his side to hunt for the
two this is where one of the most
traumatic events in Ellie's life takes
place when she happens to run into two
Hunters David and James seemingly normal
nothing to worry about and teams up with
David to take out some of the infected
but then he states that he believes
everything happens for a reason as it's
revealed that the people that attacked
Joel and Ellie at the University were
actually his men kidnapping Ellie and
then revealing themselves to be sadistic
cannibals so uh yeah not great for Ellie
right now David is essentially the
inverse of Joel at this point in the
story a man full of darkness and is
hella creepy towards Ellie referring to
her as his special little girl Ellie is
able to escape after cleaving James but
David catches up to her in an abandoned
restaurant pinning her down and he says
she doesn't even know what he's capable
of again being really creepy for anyone
at this point as he begins to choke
Ellie out luckily she reaches for a
machete and makes mincemeat of David's
face Joel shows up right at this moment
and Comforts her but the trauma of this
has stuck with her adding to the
ever-growing list of post-apocalyptic
anxiety trust issues and PTSD Ellie has
already gathered remaining quiet and
reserved for most of their trip until
Salt Lake City the only other person
that she truly trusts is Joel the
endless amount of events that the two
have gone through solidifies Joel as a
father figure to Ellie Joel and Ellie
eventually stumble upon the fireflies
held up in an old hospital in Salt Lake
City in the spring of 2034 advising Joel
had made it there just in time eliad
just turned 15 years old and is being
prepped for surgery and finally a
potential here can be researched to stop
the infection however when Joel
discovers that Ellie is going to be
essentially sacrificed for this
procedure he can't help himself
eliminating most of the fireflies the
doctors and takes Ellie back for himself
it's such a conflicting thing for Joel
to do but also Ellie wasn't entirely
aware of what would actually happen to
her during the procedure so it's really
a toss-up on whether or not she wanted
to go through with things or not Ellie
comes to in the back seat of a car as
Joel drives her back to Jackson County
she asks kind of like what happened back
at the hospital not knowing exactly what
had played out Joel Now lies to La
saying that there were dozens of immune
people and she wasn't needed anymore
Ellie seems a bit apprehensive by Joel's
response but accepts it later when they
approached Jackson Ellie finally reveals
to Joel about what had happened that day
of the bite and her friend Riley Ellie
again reinforces the survive driver's
guilt that she has saying she's still
waiting for her time Joel reassures her
that there's always something to live
for she then asks again about everything
in Salt Lake City making him swear he's
telling the truth about the hospital the
fireflies The Cure all of it after a
moment Joel responds I swear with Ellie
accepting it now it's never fully known
at this time Ellie's true feelings but
it's absolutely crushy knowing that Joel
is basically the only person that she
fully trusts and yet he lies to her
going against all of the trust issues
that she's built up life in Jackson
seems to be working for the pair Ellie
still suffering from the aftermath of
their journey is a bit more secluded and
reserved in their new lifestyle in
Jackson but Joel and her have fully
formed that father-daughter relationship
that Joel was robbed of after the
passing of Sarah during these next few
years Joel gives Ellie a guitar he found
teaching her how to play here or there
singing Pearl Jam's Future Days for the
evening that he gifted her the guitar
Joel also surprised her with a trip to a
nearby museum for her 16th birthday the
highlight of this was Ellie seen all of
the astronomy exhibits later being
surprised with a recording of the Apollo
11 launch and pretending to fly into the
stars in the year following Ellie became
much more involved with the Jackson
Community having her own Patrol route
with Dina and Jesse other members of
Jackson should be friends even becoming
romantically involved with Dina however
the idea of the fireflies and the truth
of what actually happened all those
years ago rattled around in her brain as
she rode off to find answers of her own
upon investigating the hospital and
operating room Joel caught up to her
comforting her because he was worried
but Ellie knows the truth threatening
Joel to tell the truth or she she is
completely done with him Joel then lets
her know about the vaccine but how she
wouldn't have survived the procedure
Ellie breaks down again with that
survivor's guilt bubbling up to the
surface she had a grander purpose in
life but Joel took that from her Ellie
completely devastated by this Revelation
returns back to Jackson but there's a
huge Rift between the pair Weeks Later
Ellie meets Joel at his house to discuss
everything once more pissed about the
Saving Grace Behavior she scolds him
again about stealing her meaningful
purpose in life and essentially dooming
Humanity surprisingly Joel doesn't
switch his tone at all sticking with the
fact that if he had another chance a
second chance at all of this he would do
it again even though Ellie is wrecked
beyond belief deep down she knows how
much Joel truly cares for and agrees to
forgive him but it's going to be a very
slow healing process on March 2nd Jess
see out on patrol meets up with Dina and
Ellie to let them know that Joel and
Tommy didn't make it back from their
patrol yet in a frenzy Ali tracks their
horses to the Baldwin Mansion where Joel
and Tommy had been essentially kidnapped
by a group of passerbys led by Abby
Anderson now at this moment this this
person is just a complete random another
post-apocalyptic wander buyer but Abby
happens to be the daughter of the Dr
Joel shot when rescuing Ellie from The
fireflies all of those years ago Abby
and her group were on a Revenge Mission
and finally caught Joel The Man
responsible for uh maybe dooming
Humanity may maybe pleading and
threatening them Ellie is held down by
Abby's group as she watches Joel's Last
Breath Abby grabs a golf club and
Smashes in Joel's head ending his life
Ellie in a panic promises she's going to
get her revenge but is then knocked
unconscious Joel was six when he died
and was the closest thing to a father
that Ellie had Ellie and Tommy returned
back to Jackson after Dina and Jesse
found them knocked out traumatized by
everything that transpired Ellie swears
Vengeance on Abby in the group wanting
to gather some of Jackson's Manpower and
head out to Seattle to track them down
Tommy and Maria explained to Ellie how
that's not necessarily the best idea and
to just let it go but Tommy is the one
to head out in the next morning without
Ellie Maria was left a note specifically
stating not to let Ellie follow him but
wanting her husband back Maria allows
Ellie and Dina to travel after him and
bring Tommy back in one piece Ellie and
Dina Venture into the outskirts of
Seattle attempting to locate both Tommy
and Abby's group members in doing so one
by one Ellie proves fruitful in tracking
down members of Abby's party slowly
getting one step closer to her goal of
Vengeance however over various obstacles
pop up in their way from new forms of
mutated infected to the wlf or rather
Washington Liberation Front a military
outfit similar to that ephedra on the
East Coast during this time of tracking
Ellie and Dina wander into a
spore-filled underground where Ellie's
mask is broken Dina wants to save
Ellie's life and you know offers her her
mask but then Ellie finally reveals her
immunity to the infection this of course
comes as a bit of a shock to Dina but
Dina Returns the revelations letting
Ellie know that she is pregnant with
this new information the pair hold up in
an abandoned theater to allow Dina to
rest and better formulate a plan
listening in over a wlc radio Ellie
hears of a disturbance in an area called
Hillcrest thinking that this could
potentially be Tommy upon investigation
this turns out to be Jesse who had
tracked the pair out to Seattle to help
the best he can basically they're
forming this 9 nice lovely family in the
Seattle theater as Ellie fills Jesse in
on Dina's secret of being pregnant Ellie
leaves the next day on her own having
Jesse stay back and take care of a sick
Dina Ellie again tracks down one of
Abby's group members Nora to a nearby
hospital and here you almost see the
influences of Joel in her because she
interrogates and beats Nora who's
already infected by spores demanding
that she gives up Abby's location and I
think that this is one of the first
heavily apparent times in the game of
Ellie having a turn into the path of
Darkness Joel had kind of warned about
or hinted at in his some 20-ish years
between Sarah's death and when we met
him this drove Ellie to a nearby
aquarium where Abby was said to be
holding up arriving there she only found
Owen and Mel but was able to get a jump
on the pair Elliot reasoned with them
saying that she wanted just Abby nothing
to do with them at all but things
obviously took a violent turn with Ellie
being the last one standing Ellie
suffers a severe panic attack though
when she discovers that Mel was pregnant
unable to breathe or even think straight
somebody says Ellie's name and it turns
out to be Tommy and Jesse looking for
her back at the theater Tommy persuades
Ellie that she's done enough it's time
to go home Dina being pregnant is a huge
risk for all of them Tommy heads out to
the lobby to make sure everything's all
right checking on things but is then
soon heard fighting with someone Jesse
and Ellie rushed to his aid but Jesse is
instantly shot in the face it is Abby
and a young boy named Lev Abby knows
what Ellie has been doing after finding
Owen and Mel at the aquarium and says
she shouldn't have left Tommy and Ellie
alive a fight breaks out amongst the two
different sides resulting in Tommy being
shot in the leg and losing an eye Dina
being beaten and bruised with Ellie
being the last one standing but having
her arm broken by the end of the
Skirmish Abby looks down and warns LA to
never cross paths with her again as Abby
and Lev leave Ellie looks over at Dina
thinking of Tommy and Jesse
contemplating what her actions cost her
the group returns back to Jackson to
settle into a more relaxed lifestyle
though Ellie swears revenge against Abby
she and Dina live on a farm outside of
Jackson and raise JJ Dina's newborn
together Ellie is still traumatized by
everything that transpired panic attacks
insomnia PTSD flashbacks to the day she
couldn't save Joel's life still filled
with violence and rage Ellie decides to
put the past in the past until returning
from a hunting trip to find Tommy
visiting her and Dina he informs Ellie
of Abby's latest location being located
somewhere out in the Santa Barbara area
and that she can finally get the
Vengeance that she never got Tommy would
but in his weakened state of only having
one eye now he wouldn't make it halfway
there Ellie refuses thinking of the good
life that she has now but Tommy kind of
gets the last jab in telling her to
remember the promise she made regarding
Joel later that night Ellie can't sleep
she wakes up and plays Joel's guitar and
the memories of him flow out of the
guitar persuading her to go back after
Abby one more time Dina catches Ellie
about to leave in the middle of the
night trying to persuade her to discuss
it in the morning but Ellie is convinced
no one's changing her mind as she heads
out arriving in Santa Barbara Ellie
confronts a new thread calling
themselves the Rattlers forcing
information out of one of them about
Abby's location this leads Ellie to a
resort that the Rattlers have
essentially turned into a base dozens of
prisoners locked up with them using
infected as essentially guard dogs which
that that just seems like a bad idea
freeing some of the prisoners Ellie
learns from one of them that Abby had
tried to escape weeks earlier and in
doing so her punishment was to be strung
up on a pillar on the beach having the
incoming tide smash against her and
dealing with the elements this is some
straight up medieval as Ellie finds Abby
and cuts her down at the sight of these
nightmares Ellie has a complete change
of heart from the Vengeance that drove
her there and heads for some of the
boats with Abby and Lev to escape but
right as the pair are about to shove
offshore the PTSD of Joel's death
flashes back in Ellie's memory as she
threatens Lev and demands app be fight
her the two fight in low tide and sand
slashing and punching one another Ellie
appears to have the upper hand drowning
Abby but Abby bites off two of Ellie's
fingers causing her to let up Ellie goes
even harder now continuing to drown her
but in an instant remembers Joel playing
his guitar a happy memory of his life
rather than the traumatic ending Ellie
lets up telling the pair to leave
breaking down in tears on the shore
Ellie returns back to the Jackson Farm
only to find Dina had left and it is now
abandoned in the end one of the most
heartbreaking moments from the game is
Ellie trying to play Joel's guitar she
tries to play the same song Joel was
playing the night that she confronted
him all of those years ago but after
losing a couple of fingers it's
impossible for her to strum the same
tune without messing up this small thing
that connected the two was also taken
from her as Ellie breaks down once again
leaving the guitar behind honestly The
Last of Us and last of us too are two of
the best video game stories I have ever
played emotions flew a couple of moments
from the second game and that last
guitar scene was definitely one of them
druckman and crew did a great job of
fleshing out these characters especially
Ellie a young girl who had this great
grand purpose taken from her only to
gain a family which was then taken from
her because she didn't get to fulfill
her destined purpose and the drive for
vengeance blinded her and took away the
last bit of connection she had with Joel
absolutely brilliant and gut-wrenching
when you think about it but there's
there's there's gotta be a part three
right I mean come on but yeah obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on Ellie
what parts of the game do you want to
see it brought to live action and what
do you think of Bella Ramsey's portrayal
of the character so far and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
wakanda Forever on the 15th of February
and all you gotta do to get a chance of
winning this is like this video
subscribe with notifications on and drop
your comment Down Below on the last of
us we picked the comments at random at
the end of every single month in the
winners of last month are on screen
right now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out all of our last of us coverage deep
Dives breakdowns as far as the eye can
see but with that out of the way thank
you for your constant support I've been
Jared I'll see in the next one take care
and peace